All right
then, from now on,
Prime Minister Abe, Prime Minister of Japan, and
President of the European Union, Donald Trump, President of the European Council,
I am pleased to announce that I will be attending a press conference in Japan and overseas.
First, Abe's story Then, the
chairman of the
committee has a statement.
In
response to the serious damage caused by the recent issue, the two chiefs and the chairman of the committee
thanked us for the damage in the future,
and canceled the visit to the booth.  I would like to express my sincere gratitude to you for enacting the law in place of the fact that I was forced to do so
.
The signing of the EPA clearly demonstrates to the world the unwavering political will of Japan and the EU to lead the world as standard bearers of China-China trade, even as protectionist movements spread around the world
With a population of about 600 million people
, about 30%
of GDP and about 201 trillion dollars, the world's second
largest advanced economic zone will be born.
Creating a framework
will serve as a new engine for Abenomics, which will create great opportunities for
Japan's agriculture, forestry and fisheries industries and small and medium-
sized enterprises
.
Japan and the EU, which share fundamental values, will be free and open, and will serve as the foundation
for maintaining and expanding the international order and for the peace and prosperity of the international community
.
In
today's meeting, we had a meaningful exchange of views on the various strengths being promoted between Japan and the EU.
We will continue to strengthen cooperation between Japan and the
EU based on our Indo-Pacific strategy, which is open for a reason
.  tall person  We will promote cooperation in the fields of stars, etc.
By mutually certifying the cross-border transfer of personal data in the evening edition of No. 1 between Japan and the EU today, it will be a mutual relationship between No. 1 and No. 1
.  I feel
that I am committed to completing the necessary procedures on both sides by the fall
of
2018 in order to demonstrate my commitment.  In
terms of education, culture and sports
, the first ministerial-level policy dialogue was held the other day, and we will continue to cooperate in the future.
Minimize adverse effects. I would
like to once again thank you for registering pu and providing timely and appropriate information to Japan to ensure the transparency and predictability of negotiations.
We also had meaningful discussions on the final match issue
.  The U.S.-North Korea summit meeting is a good match.It
is an attempt to break through the sky of the creator
god.On the
one hand,I feel that
North Korea has abundant support and diligent
efforts.Security is a bargain.  If I can fully stand as a candidate, I
will be able to draw a light home and war with everyone.I
will do everything in my power to work in cooperation with the international community, including the resolution of the nuclear missile issue, which seems to be the premise
of that.  Japan conveyed Japan's determination to face North Korea directly toward an early resolution,
and gained the support of the
EU.
As a partner that shares universal values ​​such as human rights and the rule of law, we will work
together with Shadow Ward and Jean-Claude
to strongly develop Japan-EU relations in all areas
and contribute to world peace and prosperity.  I would like to say that's all for
me.
Thank you very much. Now then, let's continue with the remarks of the chairman of the repair committee
.
benq g
Mr. Marty prime n da seen the
web Mr.
by pain to bu
2 f Approach and vision and natural disaster
First of all, those branches and leaves are slightly erotic
First of all, [ __ ] the other world is a cure Messer
Web ad mires & spoon
nd ring s this project
ib watching away by ah how are you
dow this prize centers party compare 6
mayo performer fuel gauge
wakayama a now phip effectors
booster specter mousse
yen de de
desu full day
4 bac the witch
makeup cooni planford peep
elop this party soon ev a lie 4
please piercing hands q 10 counts
yen loss it's a piano solo readability aloe peter make the best of winter
sit down with friends road
nde do mens japanese rap an friends
forever
Playshonzu Beads & apn 4 japan Fuzzy Barbie
Stones Graphic
Lee Grapher Police Politigar Mameguri Wig Harvey ana Closer
Weebaus Farm abeno ns 2
Operation
ruth price Ozeki
Salt Free 2
Washer Value Sofre Road
human rights andrew's blue
im proud to do state touran's marker greens p 2 e 20
b 44
japan
estee passive game
anda Comic Party Boom
ya porting Nplays Worth Spiellander Plate Dua
this arc and for ms project  Power spot Loose dice and
nurse's throne
or
tan Now it's a stream to Mark
work folding the wine
to do see life security defense
njan by met people exchange desu
insole policy wish x cultivation size japan
4 recommended interim impression hoppyong for some chapter poodle
5 as voodoo sound wave
wa  nt to see and end rep A case planpatik program
elements full support japan turn on 800 laps
boda seen the sus 4 ddr 3
japan duv my new not
na commitment making durand hard work viewer
element  Volunteers pressed to the point of supporting Fleet routes
Independent routes and day types
Shaking off the pattern in the spring battle of rice and experiencing the strada pole
screen Meeting with sour stakes To
Kankuro  230 pr
Vaporizer's Loopy Process Work Beads Mutual Pipe
3 bundles play
Thank you very much.
Japan Nante p Introduction
Boxy's Eye
India 3
bert
knap other Honorable Cipher It's already Post Pros One Burger
usa Turner System
Nogaya this Moo Piros Do your best Carpster
voodoo 05 minutes Tokyo material
1 minute 1 gather I'm sleepy why
huh 4 pizza da nosty
Pian underphone is 6mm across FM game play mic you re re dermalab
reserve
this beer tomorrow pattern spring is the voodoo 4
mom
10 gbe ad van bad voodoo akan voodoo sporty
japan
daily news power getter seeds
If
you do 4-
san produce undo
posting way
4 repeater lotus style pou dou dou
voodoo
desu grim push rs
w sa miyuki
bert tablet ba boss
well poster high stand assortment susa zurui  book
open order project
pop in pipe f to do  for
possible down
Uya making parser group of people e
face t 6 pot floating 2 or 3
boo boo se 2 do
USS pay Andy and it is straight house no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no  no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no  no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
this peres wallet roll updater
undo
Mr. Azubie Akan-san
Loose projection in projection
and with bud Aiming for a web service
Another process, even a window What a riff Itoi
It's a boom
Antares ar tights
voodoo
Booth 4
proper 4 re 4 persons
Since Vivant II it's
not this
pa
japan all windows t 5 us true to do camp
labor union
derby 4 d
Thank you very much
.
If you have asked, please state your name and the school you belong
to.For questions, we will receive answers from Prime Minister Abe, chairman of the 5th
Committee, and chairman of the Yoon family.
My name is Takayama from the newspaper company. There is a
short pause at the beginning of the prostitutes and the chairman of the committee
.
As protectionism is on the rise right now, Prime Minister Abe made a statement,
but what kind of impact do you think this
conclusion will have on the international community?
I would like to ask another point.
Please explain in detail what kind of merits there are within the region as a nation of Japan
.
Especially for Prime Minister Abe, in the trend of tilting the agricultural package.
There are still voices of unease, and I would like to answer based on the question of how to respond in the meantime
.  We will build
a fair economic neck with a free and high standard of 10% to fight a worthy battle,
and we will find out a huge economic zone that has a population of 600 million people and a thermal of the world's gdp
.
This is Japan.
I think it will be the new engine of Abenomics, which will create GDP of about 5 trillion yen and create jobs for 90,000 people
.  In
the midst of growing concerns about the protection of the
EU, I believe that the business of communicating to the world the importance of a trade system based on fair rules between Japan and the EU is extremely important.
However, we will show that by connecting
high-level PPAs based on many free and fair streets in such an environment,
we will bring great benefits to the people living in this economic zone.
I am confident that
this epa will also allow viewers and
prefectures to broaden their shopping options, such as Houju's excellent travel goods and bags
, while also allowing them to enjoy Europe's proud wines and cheese chocolates more easily.  At the same time, there is a great advantage for the consumers, such as
agriculture, forestry, fishery workers, and
employees.
That's why it
was called Kobe beef and Yubari melon, but now there are
Takita's delicious
and safe high-quality agricultural products, but someday new opportunities will
arise.  We will continue to support the agricultural, forestry and fisheries workers to achieve the target of 1 trillion yen.
100% abolishment of appraisal will bring great opportunities for business expansion.
Based on this sp aa,
we would like to further develop cooperation in various fields including security and maritime development education.
There
is some advice about a medium distance between Japan and the EU,
but within that
we will share values ​​and enter into an epa spa
.
I would like to once again express my gratitude to the two leaders and the chairman of the committee for their efforts
I want to contribute not only to the peace and prosperity of the world, but also to
artists Machiko Kuri.
The time was right for the dog
File 2
From the morning of the 4th ena or 6 eb Cafe
sweets Mansion 2 step peg spy artwork Free plating lander
Sono 2 f Living room Mozo spray down prosperity voice of japan
Spec target Mets
I want to go to the second part of the mountain
Yes, put it on me
Actually, when will I increase the imprinting darkness and the national rating
? Clean master
Yakyuken or exercise?
Lawson's blowing rice bowl with a
sound sparring scene The
same flower material Manchuria
3 If you are a starter, 1 pair of Abuja paddles.
Thank you.  Let me start with my wife.
Please
phase 2.
Please always clearly state your name and affiliation. I
'm not from Canada
.  Pasion Hmmm
A while ago,
now a strong serve is good
voodoo I've used 4 asfb people
Posco won't be done Child who likes bread
So please Prime Minister Abe
We are left behind due to this economic partnership agreement or China trade
I am well aware that there are many people in the EU, Japan, and the world who feel uneasy, and that is
why protectionism is on the rise.
If we do not make efforts to explain well and gain understanding,
we will not be able to proceed with this kind of economic partnership agreement.
Although it is not possible to do so, it does not mean that the
economic zone based on free and fair rules created by the big epa is evaluated
as good if it can afford
it.In that sense, for example, in Japan, small and medium-sized enterprises
Everyone in the agriculture, forestry and fisheries industry has written about many concerns, but under such free and fair
rules,
it is good to change clothes and work earnestly to make things that are
properly evaluated.
Opportunities will arise. As
for the uneasiness and concerns that still remain, the government
will firmly face
them and respond to them.
However, we can
revise the tpp-related policy outline
so that it corresponds to the Japan-EU EPA, and strengthen measures.
In
addition, for small and medium-sized enterprises, we will provide careful information
and develop a consultation system, and provide detailed support, including the development of new sales channels.
This correction is a big enterprise  We would like to firmly explain that this is not for the sake of large global corporations, but for
those farmers, forestry workers, and small-scale bosses
.
Please say something
nunber An tongue-tied pair living in Beijing
Farley Pink Rudu Awaza Bill Zua-kun It's
subtle
web One Pigger Disfiger Spool Viewer Roof
Eve and Jesus and 1 bn us is also a service of the actual thing I
've received it as a separate pot for this-chan  masu
Twenty Four Thirds chops
rendered good party
pass 50 minutes pou dou dou other
re use me love n
rupan no dai
ion toner bate wrs power with this company asp
pu de base?
Verity Event Ponsuburi
Well then,
re with 4
ref Pride Beam
Then, Chairperson of the Lightly Dressed Committee, Chapter 8, then?
It's a hit ball
ah ah ah It's a
flight